io aggiunge ho chieste era un po che non
facevo giocassero nota al mese sono
talmente nota vorrei fare una volta
settimana perché bellissimo però
facciamo una volta al mese per renderlo
un po più prezioso oggi vediamo quanto
conosco l'europa va bene perché non ho
mai fatto le rue per gli european union
meno se una volta capito in italia
almeno sono sicuri sbagliarla obiettivo
principale signori oggi azzeccare il
paese senza quel paese già vinto poi
dopo di che devo attaccare anche loro ma
già il paese non è male poiché siamo
dove dove potrebbe mai essere portato è
bello siamo in un quartiere residenziale
dell'uzbekistan o fece una coca eccolo
eccolo ora sì che capisco questa in
romania gli avrei detto tipo ungheria
quella roba li fece non mi sa che in
romania
saremo upload chiesti cryos sushi pool a
tutto il resto che credo sia questo qua
qua in mezzo
se c'era una città in romania che si
chiama costanza perché non c'è una città
in italia che si chiama dumitriu non
penso che se ci sia stato visto posto ma
dopo ai.bi ok pista in camp si siamo in
tedesca
devo solo capire dove sono tutti andati
oggi al westphal house
beh chi non ci va al west ham pausa
fatevi dare una via principe che bello
che bello sta roba madonna bellissimo di
star quando ragazzi veramente figo si
vede che siamo in tedesco
siamo in germania non capirò mai la
città ma mettiamo in parte legati
dottore porto trova in alto francoforte
mentre franco market polsi e turn over
sbagliato ma wagon che eravamo vicini
sempre più vicino è comunque niente male
non male ragazzina ma siamo in un punto
dove il mondo e censurato patate a fare
la foto facevate prima dove che siamo
qua sono le case belle secondo me siamo
in olanda la holland a olanda olanda
polan draga ma perché mi sa che tu puoi
richiedere la censura di casa tua dalle
mappe sono quasi convinto di questo
sarebbe molto stylish e richard gere ha
addirittura friedrich alfred street
hangout berkhout kong
o in olanda siccome siamo sempre in
germania sai a questo punto però strano
colonia può essere tutto lì era porca
vacca duisburg stavolta sempre più
vicino tra l'altro quale erano vicine a
dortmund o questa ragazzi finalmente una
questa nella germania allora spero non
sia italia perché se faccio figure di
kakà che metto che siamo in svezia data
e l'italia miss mi ammazzate giustamente
madonna perché mare
ma che cos'è questa cosa qua poi la
sardegna non è nostra rassegna
sicuramente ragazzi sarà tipo croazia o
giù di lì croazia siccome ho un posto di
tipo zara zara da zara o da pesca guarda
guarda tutto qua tutto qua tutto qua poi
a scuola avevo due però tutto qua
signore e signori il programma vere in
italia se riesco a ubik armi sapete che
non ho io ogni volta che faccio d'italia
teoricamente sbaglio di più di quando
faccio tutt'altra cosa quindi
teoricamente potrei sbagliarmi però
abbiamo la stazione centrale di catania
andata veramente bene quando ancora
c'era l'enjoy a catania che bei momenti
i ragazzi dovremmo essere teoricamente a
catania perché credo che a catania ci
sia la stazione centrale di catania
quindi se alcune di catania il godo
dovreste darmi ragione quindi speriamo
qui tipo di altezza sbagliato via vabbè
porca vacca 135 metri beh direi che non
è male ragazzi non è male o la madonna
perché caso abbiamo qua dove si è finiti
nel wyoming ristorante braceria il
prefisso e 0 2 1 quindi teoricamente
dovrebbe essere nel nord vicino la sala
tipo asti vedi come la mia testa
funziona benissimo a volte ho qua siamo
chissà se una volta becker ormai un
posto dove sono effettivamente st
madonna che bello insieme quali voi
abita qua che culo
allora diamo sfogo alla mia cultura
scherzavo filiere di san marino san
marino grande grande san marino dove san
marino ci sono stato a san marino però
non è da dire che sia questa
mi pare che sia su una collina quindi
azzarderei quasi tipo di requa così beh
però due chilometri ragazzi niente male
nest iscritti ciò di san marino bonus
pasta colorata in che senso
una confezione 453 confezioni 12 euro
io e approfitterà i ragazzi si credo sia
una città turistica perché vedo che c'è
scritto un sacco in inglese secondo me i
ragazzi siamo tipo a venezia però non
venezia nei dintorni non lo so raga
eccolo il sapere la mia testa il ponte
dei pensieri che sta dove lagonda ma io
ma io ma perché mi hanno fatto uscire
con 60 la scuola perché il melo tu ti
prego vabbè comunque qua dentro tipo
tipo qua abbiamo azzeccato la via aveva
azzeccato la via ma tu 73 metri vabbè
dai raga ciao ma veramente aveva
azzeccato la via raga madonna bellissimo
gli avanti ragazzi catania stazione
centrale ma torna come le sogliole cose
come le sogliole con fermi tutti e
questa è questa la via e questa è questa
qua la via
porca vacca sedici metri sono stato
bravissimo o milan l'è un gran milan
questa via torino ragazzi che se va via
prima del duomo che sta
eccola qua perché stavamo più o meno qui
41 m very good volo no si bologna cosa
ecco purtroppo io for bologna non l'ho
mai frequentata sono andato a bologna
solo per fare i video con space valle
non so quale sia la via pc immagino
questa sparando no porca vacca veda è
vicinissimo 200 metri io di tutto
rispetto e dire che questa partita di
tutto rispetto ne facciamo ancora uno e
basta
next dai questa è l'ultima era chiama
però niente male sono molto quando
soddisfatto di me stesso però hard
difficile è papera madonna che se lo
sfondo di windows
scusi signor rocco adesso nessuno di
essi carlo sarà qua puntato a caso come
ci azzecco io guarda mi scusi eh vabbè
quasi storpiata la videocamera
non lo so ragazzi ma come a sestola
ma cos'è ma dove non avrei mai azzeccato
va beh
bella bella festa un altro sfondo di
windows qua a caso madonna come non ci
azzecco niente era meglio finire il
video nella mappa prima ragazzi però che
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi è stato bello
fino a tra le ultime mappe e stato molto
bello
iscriviti al canale e fatemi sapere se
volete tanto bisogno di giorni esserne
giuliano prossimo episodio ho lasciato
mi piace un commento per ragazzi
[Musica]